[Musique]
là
d
oh
la presse en parle
l'a5 le montre ce soir dans un bain de
minuit info mitterrand fait craquer les
présentateurs du jt en présence de
jacques attali conseiller spécial de
tonton en plus y aura francis bacon
harlem désir
bohringer voulzy et en invité surprise
sopra jacques attali bonsoir vous
connaissez mathilda may voilà bien deux
jouer dans le dernier film de chabrol
c'est ça qui sort quand le cri du hibou
titre le 28 octobre fluence belkacem qui
va vous interviewez avec moi le rendre
aussi que je ne vous présenterai pas
richard bohringer non plus et philippe
guérin qui travaillent sur bain de
minuit avec moi à la première question
que je vais vous poser c c'est quoi la
vie d'un
conseiller spécial du président de la
république ça consiste en quoi c'est
heureusement
inattendu et d'improvisation s'essaya
rien de régulier cette chose continue
c'est le rythme du conseil des ministres
mercredi auquel j'assiste le fait d'être
tout le temps alors ce qu'il peut se
passer des événements d'accompagner le
président en voyage à l'étranger de
voyager beaucoup pour lui soit de façon
ouverte soit de façon plus discrète
et puis de voir beaucoup de gens de
réfléchir de proposer des idées de
mais annoncer les choses est ce que le
président doit toujours savoir où vous
êtes par exemple
oui quand vous partez en week end
quelque part vous dites tous vos autres
comme les médecins et on a un grand
médecin qui doit toujours savoir où
trouver comme maintenant pense pas et
vous trouvez quand on décrit alors
j'écris par définition très tôt le matin
à bombay entre 4h et 7h du matin
vous sortez pas le soir j'ai pas besoin
de beaucoup de sommeil je peux sur
touche je peux me lever très tôt
prévenir au pain jusqu'à 11 heures du
soir se gagnent beaucoup être conseiller
spécial du président de la république
spécialement payer vous pouvez nous dire
combien je suis membre du conseil d'état
oui ça fait combien cela en tant que
membre du conseil d'état je garde mes
fantasmes c'est pas terrible
et voilà ça s'arrête là c'est tout et de
quel personnage célèbre par exemple dans
l'histoire de france vous auriez aimé
être le conseiller spécial en dehors de
françois mitterrand par exemple
clemenceau baisse pierre léon blum
difficile à dire c'est une chose de
hasard jeu plus dans je pourrai plus
fixer des ambitions par rapport à
l'écriture tel ou tel grand écrivain et
que par rapport à la politique la
politique est pour moi un hasard de
ville je trouve que j'ai la chance
d'être
croisement ou un homme politique
important a eu besoin ou envie ou
d'avoir un intellectuel au près puis
ce n'est pas une finalité pour moi après
le président mitterrand est ce que vous
pensez vous envisagez pouvoir être
conseiller spécial un autre résident non
pas le pas le moins du monde
encore une fois aux etats unis c'est
assez banal cantons universitaires non
vous devez une banale de dire un
intellectuel bas pour un temps essayer
de faire avancer ses idées dans la
politique et puis ensuite il retourne
vers ses livres d'autres formes de
communication c'est mon cas c'est
pourquoi l'europe c'est très peu
fréquent en arrivant et je crois que
titien des rares dans un pays européen à
l'avoir fait il faut s'habituer à cette
idée que les intellectuels peuvent venir
jouer leur rôle dans la politique tout
en restant le même et en n'étant pas
forcément condamnés à basculer dans le
champ de l'action politique proprement
dit est ce que vous avez une fois
l'algérie est un pays fantôme avis qui
n'existe plus l'égérie vous aviez connu
qu'est ce qui vous arrive d'y retourner
d'y penser dans rêvé la nuit c'est
l'équité jay très jeune
moi je suis
je lui fais
adrien double fantôme double inexistence
dans la racine c'est peut-être ce qui
m'a plu c'est comme d'autres a joué
beaucoup dans le concept c'est à dire à
vivre sans racine c'est à dire avoir des
racines dans la tête
est ce que vous êtes croyants oui
le soir du kippour vous êtes resté chez
vous un vie privée vie privée et vous
pratiquez vie privée ne répondrai pas
bien alors on va contrer un petit sujet
qu'on a fait avec philippe b raf
on a pris un imitateur qui a pris la
voie du président mitterrand et qui a
appelé les présentateurs du journal
télévisé en leur demandant à la veille
des élections ainsi mois des élections
de parler un petit peu plus de lui de
mieux le traité dans les journaux
télévisés et vous allez voir certains
ont tout de suite découvert la
supercherie
peut-être parce que c'était ma limite et
peut-être parce qu'il pense pas que le
président mitterrand soit capable de ça
mais il y en a un et non des moindres
ici les c'est franchement attrapé alors
on va voir le sujet si vous voulez bien
d'abord comment tu avais vu monsieur
mitterrand comment dit on est correct et
oui et je voulais tout d'abord vous
féliciter personnellement je suis
monsieur mitterrand un bon coup du
bélier vraiment pas de temps à perdre
je n'ai vous féliciter pour votre
journal c'est que je suis sensible au
fait que les journalistes sûrs de l'es5
une certaine intégrité dans la période
de trouble vient de subir du visuel qui
je suis françois mitterrand
et je suis le président mais
malheureusement j'ai un rendez vous bon
vous avez vous qui est sa lave de
plaisanterie pas ce que vous voulez
c'est non non mieux vous avez vous ce
soir qu'avant j'avais vous ce soit
l'armée qui y est je suis françois
mitterrand mais normalement à tourner
dans les présentes rides que j avais
plein bureau j'ai un rendez vous dans
cinq minutes
alors il faut absolument que j'y aille
alors maintenant on va les masques aux
c'est ça tombe bien les messes
je voulus comme eux vous c'est que nous
approchons de l'échéance électorale
importante
je voulais savoir si il était possible
et d'être invité prochainement dans
votre journal et tout est possible je
serai fort plat était d'accueillir le
président de la république sans problème
mais il faut que je trouve une
opportunité je n'aime pas tellement ses
interventions officielles que nous
aimons comme par exemple le rang fabius
vous savez je vous expliquais monsieur
le président je suis un peu étonné de
coups de fil
j'ai l'impression actuellement de vote
une blague
alors j'aimerais que vous rassure y est
et ce qu'il est possible de repasser un
coup de fil s'il vous plaît à vos
services de façon vous d'avoir au
téléphone coûts de gestion
mais si ce n'est pas une plaisanterie
alors je passais toutes mes excuses
beaucoup plaisir vraiment d'airé est ce
moment là ce que je vous propose c'est
tout simplement dû rappeler l'isi au 42
92 81 00 parce que je vais recevoir et
le président du conseil italien a pu
assez rapidement je voulais vous
remercier personnellement pour eux l
émission de et de christine ockrent de
grande qualité nous entretenir une autre
émission
j'aimerais pc dans une émission autre
que le journal ou et spécial souhaité
également sur un truc et que madame
autres qu'elle l'est vous en êtes et le
parler alors vous en êtes élu par les
ados oui commentant d allô allô monsieur
mougeotte
ce que je postulais problème pour moi je
vous vous demandez comment expliquer
soit mitterrand parle au téléphone parce
que on s'est trouvé devant un imitateur
il a fallu lui dire essayer de ne pas
faire de limitation de seine m'essayer
de faire de limitation de conversations
intimes sais pas je ne suis pas un
imitateur dont je ne saurais vous
répondre je n'ai pas de trouver que ce
soit très précis dans le vocabulaire
mais comment est-ce que par exemple
quand il vous appelle il dit à lauzach
allô monsieur attali comme les détails
matériels font que ce ça ne se passe pas
comme ça c'est vrai que c'est lui qui
appelle ce qui lui arrive des fois de
composer lui-même le téléphone au numéro
et que la personne au bout du fil disent
non n'êtes pas françois mitterrand oui
bien sûr que ça j'ai un aigle une
anecdote qui est arrivé et non pas lui
mais un de ses prédécesseurs
chaque page en afrique a sur son bureau
plusieurs téléphones ne sont pas sur les
détails d'un thème et un téléphone qui
est une simple ligne de communication de
ptt est ici
le président pompidou art si un jour une
communication comme ça quelqu'un qui
téléphone et qui insistaient beaucoup
pour parler à la personne qu'elle
croyait pas au bout du fil et les
malfrats qui vous est il arrivé il a
répondu en tout cas at il raconté à
madame si vous aviez c'est vrai que ça
arrive parfois il arrive que le
président assad ils peuvent téléphoner
il téléphone très souvent lui même il
peut très bien avoir téléphoné à des
journalistes m et ça vous ça vous
vous étonne que ce soit le présentateur
du journal télévisé du service public
qui s'en aperçoivent pas vous y voyez
quelque chose de structurel ou au
contraire est-ce que ça vous sagnier
mois habitués que les souffrances qu'ils
ont bien de ça oui c'est oui c'est parce
qu'ils débutent et qui n'a pas encore
reçu de coups de téléphone de m les
autres connaissent sa voix sans doute
fait richard hill à dire très humain ces
précisions de la lumière téléphone
lui-même sympathies conservatrices en
pâtit non mais c'est pas lui c'est ce
que tu penses que le président de la
république peut appeler les gens comme
ça pour leur demander de parler un peu
plus de lui et les télévisions ou est ce
que ça te sens tu du niveau des supers
sur eux je pense que c'est pas possible
c'est à peine si l'enjeu pense pas je
pense pas qu'il y ait des gens pour ça
que je crois que c'est jacky appelle
même pas sûr enfin je sais pas
lunettes noires pour nuits blanches
voici l'album sylvain bergère ça
commence la nouvelle eve soirée maillot
de bain c'est en face le martial on va
en parler tout à l'heure
[Musique]
les french kiss au palace on reconnaît
sa peau au passage
[Musique]
hubert mari pour les coulisses de 20 de
minuit avec richard berry cécilia noah
et si on la croit j j farid
lalanne et de gipsy kings les chouchous
babet à l'idée roda gil
et la feria des vendanges à nîmes avec
unique dans l'histoire de la tauromachie
deux stars des années 60 70 mètres
l'habit de lumière à leurs enfants
réciproque
les jeunes literie et camino
la feria c'est les corridas mais c'est
aussi le pastis omet dans les bodégas à
paris ça se passe au district au 49 rue
berkshire
dussollier
et encore marie décidément
tu as changé un petit aspect fort ok oui
les johann strauss
vous êtes héloïse c'est ça et vous êtes
pour martial fait du strip-teaseur
martial de temps en temps pas tous les
soirs
jean rouzaud c'est toi qui a fait le
sujet sur une marche sur le martial vrai
tournant nuit vous allez voir tout à
l'heure dans leur après avec colas jean
pierre ancelin qui est le patron en
patron du marché c'est à pigalle à tapis
gaz pour ça que des miettes toi si le
soleil est c'est le soleil salue
alexandra tuyaux martial aussi est ce
que tu fais tu y arrives tequila c'est
toi qui sert et éclaire un peu au fait
de la pub pour de code dans notre
émission
que ça toute façon je sois tu en feras
une après tout ce que j'aime à préciser
tout est serveuse porte-jarretelles et
voilà c'est un tribun aux profs c'est
bien c'est bien c'est égal moderne
ouais vraiment mieux qu'avant je crois
tu pas nous faire rapido alors là pour
voir recette jours alors un verre un
petit kilo j'espère que je vais jouer
que ce soit
déjà on va croître en a fait exprès pour
monter avec super schumi
[Musique]
et après on tape non ouais mais là je
suis pas taper sur la table c'est là
tout vérifier bah si tu me l'avais fait
je la bois
[Musique]
oh
oui c'est terrible voilà vous n'êtes pas
finie et ça c'est ce que tu sers aux
gens tout le monde en bois au fond voir
combien ça dépend des gens il y en a au
bout de trois et ont bien en tout 15
battu à mort faire une croix dans le
sujet alors on peut citer qui la
chouette way out redoutable tu veux pas
essayer quand même je suis vachement
seriez déjà loupé lot c'est qui ton
toubib un must et aux pattes vachement
bien parce qu'il tient lieu moins bombée
si on peut envoyer ce sujet alors on va
regarder ce qui se passe tous les soirs
où martial ces gens qui rentrent sains
paris
samedi
moi
[Musique]
bonsoir francis bacon merci d'être venu
ici au bas je crois que vous connaissiez
vous connaissez cette boîte de nuit
avant malheureusement pas non ça allait
à terme en intéressant vraiment je
voudrais vous dire vous allez me dire ou
es tu fais ça je viens vous allez au
palace à l'époque de terrorisme oui je
suis allé deux ou trois fois parce que
j'avais connu par la bri
un peu et
voilà mais c'est déterminer ce qu'elle
fasse tout ce que tu peux arriver à lui
mais sa vie est tellement dur n'est ce
pas je travaille toute la nuit dans
l'es2 vous invitons les deux boîtes
mais oui c'est un homme de la nuit mais
vous aussi vous êtes un homme de la nuit
vous travaillez là même la nuit
vous travaillez la nuit où vous allez
dans les moeurs jeu d'habitude je suis
dans les bars et parce que je trouvais
très bonne heure le matin je me lève de
contribuer à la lumière et je commence à
ces moments de ce travail j'ai jusqu'à
minuit à midi ou à une heure et puis je
dresse la journée pour moi pour boire et
pour passer la vie avec les autres et
vous avez bien boire qu'est ce que ça
vous a pas qu'il reste en jaune
non vous savez je veux c'est en russie
en italie voilà qu'est ce que vous
voulez il veut il vaut mieux vivre pour
oublier la réalité ou
quoi pas
parce qu'en fait dans vos tableaux dans
votre peinture vous raconter c'est un
peu là la solitude la mort la difficulté
d'être le quel est le vous préférez la
réalité ou le ou la cruauté de votre
peinture parce que c'est un monde en
fait
traduction mais lundi et cohérent et
silva plus cruel que vos peintures
beaucoup plus quoi
et on
on sait vraiment quand on parle de ce
côté de ma peinture
il faut penser à l'avenir et on passe la
vie bras dessus bras dessous avec
l'homme avec la mort la mort nous
accompagne toujours
[Musique]
et dans vos dents au tableau vous pour
vous peignez essentiellement des
portraits
quels sont les très souvent les gens
sont beaux et quand une fois pas ici de
vienne les clés de votre notion de la
laideur et de la beauté cela je pars la
même chose bien sûr mais d'habitude je
fais la portée des gens que je connais
bien parce que et gens j'aime voit les
fêtes les gens beaux mais tant en
travaillons on est
on les fait souvent l'aise parce que ça
marche pas mieux dans le
dans le sens et
de la vie les deux sens de l'esthétique
ça m'a souvent mieux parce qu'il
faudrait former la vie pour le voudrez
pour vous rappeler à la réalité est
déformée la vie pour nous pour mieux la
retrouver
oui vous êtes aujourd'hui sans doute que
le plus grand peintre vivant au japon
jamais cette question savez ça passe
tellement vite il est allé moment voilà
en deux jours on trouve un autre quand
quentin grb aigner il pleurait très
souvent avant d'attaquer un tableau
surtout quand c'est un portrait alors
vous vous peignez essentiellement des
portraits
est-ce que vous avez ce sentiment de
danger de mort tant que vous peignez
c'est pas qu'en semaine y en a toujours
et toujours
on s'est toujours autour d'un souper à
la mort quand on est très jeune en pense
pas cette chose là mais avec l'âge savez
ça forcément ça c'est c'est puis en
glissant que la boisson vous avez
commencé à peindre en fait assez tard
vers l'âge de 30 ans oui c'est ça qu'est
ce que vous faisiez avant d'en avant a
joué pendant vous étiez valeurs je suis
enceinte de choses oui j'ai pu parler de
chance je fais tout quand j'avais un peu
j'avais quand j'avais un peu la gent
je me disais seulement pendant je
n'avais pas envie rien faire vous aimiez
le jeu je crois non j'adore le jeu parce
que de temps en temps ça m'a beaucoup
aidé mais vous savez à la fin et perdu
j'ai perdu beaucoup mais je veux encore
poker non je joue là bas
le jeu le plus belge - là-haut l'aise
parce que c'est seulement là où je vais
souvent gagné vous avez un numéro ou
plusieurs numéros favoris parle pas tout
à fait non ça change aujourd'hui de
jouer encore oui je joue parce que vous
savez maintenant à londres on peut jouer
il y attend de caséine sommes partout ça
vous combien une toile de francis bacon
aujourd'hui comme une toile de vous vous
combien à peu près à ça je sais pas
parce que c'est ce que la carie me donne
et c'est ce qui est à quel prix les
vents moi je sais pas non est ce que
vous vous souhaitez que vos oeuvres soit
dans un musée bacon après un après goût
elle souhaite avoir une fondation noms
font rire sinon je n'aime pas toutes ses
formes d'art siens quand on a en a fait
maintenant un peu partout ça vous gêne
pas que ce soient éparpillés
comment que ça vous gêne pas qu'il y en
ait un peu partout dans tous les pays du
monde dans ses rangs collectionner mais
pas envie de voir ça quelque part dont
vous vous amusez v4 nous c'est quoi la
vie d'un tableau une fois que vous
l'avez fini l'idéal pour vous c'est quoi
que ce fût le cas pour sa part chez moi
et voilà j'en vois tout de suite à la
galerie et voici le bon ils vont pas
souvent pose mes tableaux sont toujours
très difficiles à vente
quel est votre production vous tenez
comme un tableau par semaine
la semaine non je ne vais pas vous savez
par semaine par mois ce n'est pas moi
par an
on sait pas avec ses deux hôtes war
c'est quand j'étais peut-être deux
sommes hélas les vingt toiles sont
exposées à la galerie lelong rues de
téhéran à paris son seul travail le
fruit de combien de deux ans dopé mais
ce qui est curé une rupture c'est que
depuis le début depuis les premières
crucifixion 1943 quelque chose comme ça
jour ce cas aujourd'hui
c'est toujours le même travail la même
obsession on retrouve notamment
l'obsession du sens là qui est
concrétisé par une toile ou seulement
une tâche de sang
vous avez quand j'ai fait les rectrices
fiction 7 et part parce que ce ne suis
pas du tout religieux mais il est on
avait des crucifixions qui m'a beaucoup
touché comme l'école par télé
c'est un autre de tuer mabhouh et et les
gens comme ça mais c'était alors à cette
époque là quand j'ai commencé je n'avais
pas vraiment un sujet alors sept à cause
de ses tableaux que j'aime énormément
les gaules vague et je ma peau et que
j'ai commencé avec les crucifixions mais
c'est pas parce que je suis réligieux
que j'avais les deux fictions c'était un
test d'un sujet et qu'est ce qui a
déclenché en fait votre goût pour la
peinture votre attirance pour la
peinture comme vous êtes dit je vais
devenir peintre
c'est une exposition picasso à paris en
ce sens j'ai vu oui j'ai vu une
exclusion par un picasso s'est hissée
rosenberg à cette époque là je vois ces
mêmes parler l épique à ce que je
préfère mais en même temps je pensais à
pourquoi je peux pas signer vers la
peinture origine c'est ambitieux
ambitieux oui tu t'appelles comment qui
a trait à est-ce que tu connais one way
est ce que tu sais que peuvent si elles
charlet étaient les choristes de web
il sait pas là ils ont quitté ces deux
hommes se séparer
ils ont quitté wam elle aussi il est en
fait un morceau qui s'appelle can't give
my love
ça n'intéresse pas pour pas plus que ça
on va le regarder quand même
[Musique]
thomas
où
puis
[Musique]
voilà
m
oh
il
[Musique]
à
c'est tout
[Musique]
il
mais
[Musique]
il est pour la quatrième semaine on va
présenter des wannabe mais je reçois des
lettres toi aussi et les gens ne savent
pas ce que c'est qu'un live agissant
l'habitude de dire newcomers alors nous
on a inventé un nouveau mot c'est wanna
be voilà je viens d'où la scène et de la
chanson des beatles à wanna be loved by
you wanna be your star et donc il faut
pas confondre avec les gonna be gone à
gonna be c'est un mec qui est sûr d'y
être humble avis un mec veut et cela il
veut à ce saint vallier seulement fin on
ne sait pas mon espère pour eux alors je
vois bien qu'on va voir là il s'appelle
proust et il est tombé dans le domaine
en mai dans le domaine ya pas longtemps
et lui il a inventé un attelage de
cheval sumériens sumériens absolument
inédit bonjour je m'appelle stéphane
proust
je viens de la banlieue au plus tôt de
la beaulieu à la lisière la campagne
puis je viens ce soir pour vous
présenter une voiture à cheval
alors elle est complètement original
parce que c'est le temps le temps des
sumériens c'est-à-dire il ya 5000 ans
avant jésus-christ 1 3000 ans avant
jésus christ est déjà pas mal
et puis depuis rien et puis c'est un
système qui permet aux gens d'être
derrière le cheval sur une voiture à
cheval bien sûr j'ai rien dégoûté quand
même mais qui laisse le cheval libre et
qui permettent à n'importe qui de monter
dans une voiture à cheval et de se
sentir en confiance et de partir suivre
une grande aventure n'importe où
n'importe où en dehors des chemins
faire des raids essai destiné à tout le
monde
des petits des grands et vous allez la
voir
et puis au mot numéro de téléphone si
vous voulez être reçu et qui partir et
laisser votre voiture prendre une
voiture à cheval des instantanément vous
retrouver dans la campagne mon numéro de
téléphone
34 70 50 34 je répète 34 70 50 34
bonsoir je m'appelle lyonel cros j'ai 25
ans je faisais du théâtre maintenant je
fais du théâtre dans la mode dans la
mode à fond drake martins avec des bouts
de métal des cas ces deux collèges des
choses folles les crinolines ça
m'empêche pas toujours de vouloir être
acteur j'ai besoin de blaise qui voulez
vous m'appelez aux 4 500 à 8 83 47
bonsoir je m'appelle judith dupasquier
23 ans j'ai pas du tout l'habitude de de
ce côté là de la caméra je suis toujours
de l'autre côté puisque je suis
réalisatrice de films ce qui me
passionne c'est de faire découvrir un
public des choses qu'il n'a jamais vous
jamais entendu
à partir du moment où je dois en faire
un film n'importe quel sujet devient
pour moi une passion ce soit un bâtiment
une entreprise un objet une personne un
musée ou un artiste je suis très
sérieuse vous pouvez me faire confiance
si vous voulez vendre des montres et
expliquer ou faire connaître quoi que ce
soit à qui que ce soit avec une petite
équipe de bons techniciens je m'en
charge en vidéo ou un film au téléphone
45 49 35 95
bonsoir d'après l'état civil je
m'appelle franck de lubac j'ai 25 ans je
suis
mannequin mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est
travailler comme comédien
malheureusement j'ai une cicatrice et ça
rebute beaucoup de gens malgré qu en 66
adressé un milieu artistique
alors si des fois il ya des gens qui
sont vraiment des artistes qui
travaillent avec leurs tripes qui veut
faire travailler un comédien balafré qui
ne faut pas obligatoirement un boyau
ils peuvent toujours m'appeler au 48 25
75 59 90 pc les cibles bonsoir je
m'appelle camry n 10 je suis venu pour
vous présenter mes chapeaux d'ailleurs
vous les avez vus partout sur les murs
de paris dans les journaux à la
télévision et au cinéma
vous ne saviez pas désolé moi si vous
voulez en avoir d'autres dans le même
genre et des robes d'aussi spectaculaire
je peux vous en faire contactez-moi 48
24 88 64 montrichard flag
on est tout le temps que c'est un film
de jacques sentiers celui et joué dans
les chevaliers du ciel
ouais mais ce qu'on dit pas c'est que
c'est un scénario de simon mickael qui
est qui a écrit avec vous quand même
ouais tout un ancien chai qui est un
ancien fait ouais
ici aussi au sujet de taxes dit aussi
que c'est pas forcément c'est pas
forcément un film de fiction
c'est aussi un signe d'amitié quoi
entre plusieurs personnages dont deux
spécifiquement pierre arditi et puis il
ya plein de rôles secondaires qui sont
aussi intéressants comme nous que dans
les séries b quoi c'est un bon série b
tu crois que ça va marcher
bah de toute façon je l'espère il ya
combien de temps pour marcher le fil
barilla il a une quinzaine de jours pour
s'installer pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il ya
derrière
parce que derrière il ya celle ci me
très très fort que ça full metal jacket
kubrick
elle filme de working fernand seguin
fernand il y a
il ya film de michael cimino avec
l'estac lambert il ya le même jour que
nous le film de louis malle
je veux dire donc passé c'est un film
qui est un atmosphère plein d'humanité
comme ça plein d'émotions
c'est vrai que c'est un pour moi en tous
les cas il faut justement c'est aussi un
grand rôle émotionnel des très bien dit
dont il ya des acteurs comme de niro qui
change de de film en film une fois il
prend 12 kilos pour jouer un boxeur
après il a le crâne rasé et toi on a
l'impression que le film en film tu es
tu es toujours bohringer qui traverse
tous les films avec un c'est pas
reproche à moi mais tu le sens ça
quand je compte grossit grossit ou s'en
rende compte quoi bon ce moment je suis
un peu patapouf pathway parce que je
vais ça les déclics bois il ya quelqu'un
hier en voyant une émission de
télévision avec moi qui a dit c'est le
futur gamin tu crois que je t'attendrai
ça pour tuer les bons parce que ça parce
que je n'ai entendu je vais d'abord
essayer d'être bohringer quoi j'ai une
grande admiration pour lui
surtout la première période de sa
carrière qui était absolument magnifique
d'un jeune premier un extraordinaire un
homme de 40 ans même si j'ai surtout ici
avec moi et puis deux
choisir les rôles comme ça puis les
partenaires appuient parce que la
demande en flag il ya quand même un
paquet partenaires didier et final
étonnant philippines
gentil moi en ce moment tu fais tu fais
la promo du feu en douane en pleine
émission de télé
c'est la barbade minuit laquelle tu
laquelle tu préfères fais moi le hit
parade des émissions de télé par richard
bohringer ce que j' étais là jusqu'à
maintenant vu ce que tu vas faire parce
que bon denizo tu connais dans les eaux
je veux la faire j'aime bien faire 3 18
19 j'aime bien aussi parce que tu vas me
dire que tu les aimes tous du moins
celle que tu préfères ce que je préfère
ouais bah elles se sont relativement
bien passé jusqu'à maintenant on va pas
rendre mais dans l'est
de trop disons que celle de gildas ça
m'a bien plu que c'était rigolo ça me
permet d'être un peu moins ça je sais
rien aussi ouais donc toutes les
émissions dans lesquelles je me sens
bien et je peux rire parce que les
choses sont drôles je pense que
et celle que tu feras pas et que tu
aurais bien aimé faire si je les fais
pas
tu m as bien les faire non je dis que
enfin ça tombe bien
ça tombe bien parce que curieusement il
y en a que je ne fais jamais
curieusement peut-être qu'à un moment
j'aurais aimé les faire mais puisque
c'est comme ça bas j'aimerais parler et
il m'a trouvé le temps de faire ton
bocal
défini il a maintenant il est fini non
je fasse appel c'est sur lui c'est beau
une ville la nuit c'est beau une ville
la nuit qu'il a terminé à trouver un
éditeur
ouais de s'éclipser bien bas c'est super
c'est chez pivot alors saisir je passais
chypre
bien sûr la crise
ce style vocal lui plaît
j'ai toutes mes chances tarde balance
les bras
je parle de la nuit je parle des pages
tard de l'amour blessés et la moquerie
enfin est-ce que tu parles de ton père
[Musique]
non
c'est à marquer le fait d'avoir un père
qui faisait partie de la wehrmacht ça te
sens tu étais petit y penser dès fois
j'étais adolescent la semaine
puis après j'ai compris des treks j'ai
compris que chacun est prêt
chacun vivait son destin vite pour se
débarrasser de cette histoire là bas
non je me débarrassais 2
je me débarrasse lors rien parce que je
m'aperçois avec un peu de recul que
toutes les choses qui a empêché
en négatif d'une
je les regarde en souriant que
maintenant et en me disant ça m'a rempli
le sac à dos depuis j'avais bien besoin
d'avoir un grand sac à dos pour
peut-être un bon acteur quoi bien faire
mon boulot avoir la mémoire de ce que
j'ai vécu la mémoire de ce que vivent
les autres au hasard me rends compte
continue de sortir la nuit parce que
tout à l'heure quand on regarde et le
sujet sur le martial on s'est aperçu
qu'ils n'étaient pas allés que tu viens
au bar de temps en temps mais on
partirait pas ce que je suis
à vrai dire j'aime j'aime les femmes
j'aime les filles c'est pour ça que tout
à l'heure j'ai pas rose mais pas ouvert
et je n'aime pas beaucoup ces endroits
parce que où il ya j'aime fabulous et un
peu d'exploitation définies par l'homme
ouais enfin ce serait un grand discours
sa non c'est que j'aime pas c'est que je
n'aime pas ces endroits c'est que je
vais plutôt dans les endroits où où les
hommes ou les amender et des vertiges
une espèce de délire sur blanche neige
ou sur la sur la fille qu'ils ont envie
de rencontrer qui doit avoir les yeux
vers gomis yeux violets
mais mes fantasmes de qu il existe comme
tous les mecs mais j'ai pas envie
mais gagner c'est pourquoi c'est pas mon
truc je préfère parler des trains je
viens quand et comme ça alors là écrit
des poèmes est ce que tu en as à me dire
d'attendre dans la tête rien
ce matin là nous avons pris un grand
bateau gris l'un des gruissanais d'un
mot mousseline blanche traverser
l'atlantique avec mamie est aussi
cheveux blancs là où sur la dune être et
capitaine mort garde à moitié marin
sirène il envoie des baisers au loin
qu'elle est belle la gonzesse qui vit en
ville de l'autre côté du pont
qu'elle est belle je suis sûr qu'elle
ait du pognon c'est malik hindi touche
pas le sens tu vas aller au ballon il
ballon dans l'eau ça va te faire prendre
trois mamies c'est une dure on se barre
avec les économies de son patron elle a
dit c'est pas normal que tu fasses ta
vie dans ce pays cités madame x est une
dure elle à un pétard dans son cas
d'haïti comme ça c'est si jamais on nous
empêcher d'aller là bas elle était bien
dans la mrc
merci aussi
thierry tourné au vestiaire des bains
avec ce bar chinois de l'époque brusque
revisité par philippe starck au début
des 80 the wild ones le best way to die
d
au cha
de fait armées courtois
pour ses alliés dans le monde
ouais
chez eux
[Musique]
non
allez zou
[Musique]
temps
mon jeu
[Musique]
nous avions
à ce niveau les meilleurs
fini
[Musique]
go
suite
alors
[Musique]
ok
tout
soir
bon
[Musique]
des jo
nous
m
ah ah
[Musique]
denney
jo
je n'ai pas fait
moreau
non
que ce soit
m
c'est une chose
[Musique]
oh
hélas
m
c'est nous
[Musique]
et
miss
[Musique]
et
ducasse
[Musique]
hélas
adieu
pour le tc toujours je me suis rendu
compte y avait quelque chose ce matin je
sors dans la rue tout court
je crois qu elle n'a rien fait depuis la
voie
bon alors chaque vol couvre les beatles
oui c'est le tuer be telo là dedans
comment on doit dire c'est bien je ne
vous aime pas mal c'est est ce que tu es
le plus gros beats et de l'autre
français basque on le dit on le dit
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres be telo locke
dans le monde
ah oui oui lesquelles par exemple pas
aux états unis un garçon qui s'appelle
marc l'epide marque rapidos ouais
m'enfin lui se spécialise dans les
gadgets dans le
truc typîque typique fans questionne
j'apprécie beaucoup en angleterre qui
s'appelle marc hé oui choque c'est un
anglais parce qu'il est plus fort que
toi
ah oui complètement coup plus fort que
le vénère tu le vénère que bongo dans
tous les cas ça c'est le bouquin qu'on
aurait aimé avoir à l'époque quand les
les disques sortent et parce qu'on sait
qui a écrit quoi ça y est la seconde a
essayé de d'emmener les gens dont les
studios et les beatles le comment on
peut savoir si c'est mc cartney ou
lennon qui a écrit la chanson peut
d'abord ils le disent eux-mêmes dans les
interviews avant moi j'ai jamais lu ça
je peux viens viens j'étais faire
écouter la les archives du club des
quatre de liverpool
et puis aussi il ya quand même un truc
c'est qu'en général lorsqu'une chanson à
des chocs a été chanté par macartney
s'était opposé par la carte
on s'était reynolds s'était les hommes
et entre les mac arnéguy du point fr
ça dépend des compositions s'est répandu
sur un truc comme sur vos écrits ce
rêveur je veux dire c'est imbattable
j'ai été très triste quand ils sont
séparés est-ce que ça a été le plus
triste moment de ta vie j'ai fait
tellement eu le temps de réfléchir parce
que j'ai été obligé de travailler
normalement avec les mass médias ça dure
une dizaine de jours de 6 heures du
matin jusqu'à 3 heures du matin
j'ai pas vraiment le temps de réfléchir
c'est après on peut tout à fait mais
cela dit
il ya une interview que john avait donné
à l'époque pour playboy dans laquelle il
disait
je choisis le
le camp des vivants
culte des héros morts c'est des choses
j'en ai rien à fuir mais je me suis
rendu compte qu'il fallait surtout pas
tomber dans ce piège donc c'est dans
cette interview il m'a énormément l'été
jacques attali est ce que vous pensez
comme alain finkielkraut que mozart
c'est mieux que les beatles se moquer de
culture que d'essayer de comparer les
choses ont besoin est
dans ce
don de dieu
et d'ailleurs mais les
les beatles aussi tu as ou six incarne
une époque comme mozart sur des tas de
choses sur le rôle que vous avez joué à
une certaine époque pour une autre
société des beatles en 62 63 indique
bien avant tout le monde qui va se
passer les révoltes dans les villes que
la jeunesse commence à ne plus supporter
le mode de vie occidental et la
croissance et tout ce que ça donne et
dans les chansons des beatles de 63 64
il ya ce qui va se passer dans les
banlieues noir de de la santé mais c'est
ce qui va se passer mais ce qui reste
patient de suite en france et en italie
donc la musique la commande comme ceux
du 20e siècle avec mozart est en avance
sur tous les autres arbres
mais les deux rien a marre de n'être
violents des barrières en fait mais
reconnaître indice de mozart en syrie 10
de copains dont la disparition est ce
qu'on peut mettre un disque des beatles
et à discuter apolline quintrand je
pense qu'on a osé comparer les beatles
et les rolling stones à une époque nous
alors que les rolling stones ça a
toujours été ça y est parce que les
stones c'est de gratter là où ça démange
et la jeunesse vaut miser pour sa lula
vous l'avait épousée parce qu'ils
préfèrent les stones en vitesse
laurent oui les beatles donc le 5
octobre 65 le 5 octobre 87
moi je ne savais pas quand j'ai demandé
de jouer après quelques morceaux des
beatles que c'était le grand
anniversaire je vais pas non plus tu
savais pas où ça va être une grande
soirée
ouais donc je vais a pris aussi bien des
chanteurs français qui a été le plus
inspiré par les beatles qu'en maintenant
je crois qu'on ait beaucoup quoi on est
beaucoup mais
vaguement 7x l'étiquette du j'accède
parce qu' il vaut mieux être comparé aux
beatles kaki car henri salvador
henri salvador c'est bien ici que chaque
personne
on va russie à la télé chaque personne
alors mais il y en a d'autres
non non mais c'est bien c'est je sais
pas si je fais partie d'une génération
qui a été marqué par sa fin il ya
d'autres choses qui m'ont beaucoup
marqué l'époque je jouais beaucoup de
musique brésilienne dans son champ c'est
les rênes et toi tu es ma carte mais
c'est pas ça non je crois vous êtes
vaches et veaux comme disait jacques
volle couvre tout à l'heure d'abord on
n'est pas fâchés d'abord je vais pas
s'ils sont vraiment fâché mais c'est
tout d'abord et ensuite je crois qu'ils
écrivaient vraiment leurs chansons
séparément souvent
même des jeunes déjà dès le début tandis
que nous on écrit relativement ensemble
ah ouais relativement béchard les
beatles de 25 ans a rajeuni personnes là
quand même un pianiste de jazz new flyer
qui va brancher sur les beatles sur les
rolling stones d'ailleurs aussi un jazzy
be bop qui était complètement électrisé
par la musique qui arrivait et qui a le
groupe pas mal d'autres jasik espère
très très fermé tous les mouvements
musicaux est vraiment vraiment sûrs
celui-là relayeur treguer qui avaient le
coeur et l'envié d'en faire partager les
autres ils étaient fous de joie que nous
y fait souvent remarquer
jazz était beaucoup plus sectaires que
les gens du classique qui voyait pas
grand mal à venir contre les meilleurs
alors que les gens de jazz où ils sont
très très moyenne différence entre ceux
qui sont au sommet
de la musique classique ce qu'ils sont
des
des exécutants et des gens qui sont dans
des grandes formations et des mélomanes
car les mélomanes eux sont très sectaire
et regarde mais quand sting a fait son
album avec les frères marsalis et eu un
mouvement de boycott des frères marcel
wyss qui feront une tournée là c'est les
enfants du roi qui commence alors la
regarder à
un style unique c'est patrick c'est quoi
c'est la caverne
oui c'est l'une des premières
apparitions dans un eurostar avec la
beetle en outre 62 à la caverne et ils
interprètent une chanson qu'ils n'ont
pas grimpé après nantes
c'est pas un morceau de ça c'est pas un
morceau de ses morceaux dont je pensais
un truc tellement parlé de bruxelles
rôle de sam des ciels morceaux des
beatles connus qu'en fin avant après
tony sheridan cousine gwangju pas de la
batterie love me do
les personnes c'est aussi le zimbabwe ça
c'est après la colombie on va regarder
l'extrait sauvegardé sa médaille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g
m
oh
[Musique]
il
bon alors je t'ai demandé de préparer
quelques questions pour les gens qui
sont autour de la table normes basiques
1,13 à ses deux chats qu'ils soient à
bas manoeuvre originales de cadeaux
je ne sais pas little bob bon toi alors
le titre original de l'album please
please me non je te bénis pas dur bien
que tally qui doit savoir parce qu'il
s'est écoulé il est conseiller spécial
dépressif qui est jamais sorti chez
huawei il n'a jamais été imprimé une
fille tout blanc non je t'avais dit
palais par ailleurs c'est pas des prix
selon ansa
alors je vais je vais être un peu plus
ses heures réponse par dessus son bel
élan love me do dans la vidéo y ait une
influence de 2 8 2 sur cette année 62
alors je voudrais savoir lesquels
seulement on se demande pourquoi elle a
épousé est aussi de voir s'il va
demander le divorce dans les jours qui
viennent de poser les questions de santé
qu'on s'en remettra c'est un foyer irina
b you de calcul cette fois c'est juste
avant que tu en avais marre de ce côté
collectionne la convention c'est pas
forcément c'est l'intérêt même de la
chanson est ce que ces jachères ce livre
pour qu'ils nous lâchent
est-ce que ça j'aurais pu répondre aux
questions si j'avais le vrai qu'il a
rangé le président arranger tout ça
vient de vivre des centaines de réponses
non je ne fais pas mon ami de chez
source télé le batteur qui a remplacé
ringo starr pour la tournée australienne
de 64 nicole jimmy nicholl qui jouait de
la batterie sur baky de vidéos et c'est
ça alors c'était paul mccartney by jo on
aime ça se termine mieux
[Musique]
et
arem un soir je suis rentré chez moi
j'ai allumé la télé je pensais pas
regarder la télé ce soir là je t'ai vu à
l'heure de vérité
je suis resté tout seul sur mon lit
jusqu'à la fin le téléphone sonnait je
laissais le répondeur prendre les
messages
j'ai eu souvent les larmes aux yeux
parce que je trouve que ce soir là tu as
atteint quelque chose de grand c'est à
dire qu'au delà des prises de position
politiques ou sociales
tu as été humain humanis sans doute et
humains certainement
[Musique]
tout le monde te la dit je voulais te le
dire moi aussi et je veux savoir ce que
cette cette soirée a changé dans ta vie
je te remercie c'est ce qui ce qui est
mouvant c'est qu'il ya plein de gens qui
nous ont rappelés après l'émission
j'ai reçu beaucoup de courrier j'ai pas
encore pu répondre à tous d'ailleurs
et je crois que le message de sos est un
peu mieux passé c'est vrai que pour la
première fois on a eu le temps de
restituer la cohérence de ce qu'on peut
être faire comprendre que on fait des
concerts parce qu'on aime bien la fête
mais on fait aussi de l'action concrète
de solidarité sur le terrain que c'est
vrai que des fois on apparaît un peu
comme des des agitateurs des gens qui
embête parce qu'ils viennent dénoncer
d'une telle agression telles
déclarations racistes mais que c'est pas
simplement pour le plaisir de dénoncer
c'est parce qu'on a un espoir un espèce
de rêve comme disait martin luther king
c'est que demain tous ceux qui sont
venus ici pour travailler tous leurs
enfants qui sont nés quelle que soit
leur origine
et puis se sentir bien en france et que
les autres puissent bien les accueillir
c'est bon c'est changer mon avis est ce
que tu as eu le sentiment d'être
définitivement admis dans la dans la
communauté française maintenu comme un
partisan mais comme comme inconnu
manistes com
que cassard est un humanisme
aujourd'hui oui cassin et tous ceux qui
après la guerre on dise on dit plus
jamais ça plus jamais la barbarie nazie
qui ont fait la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme
je crois qu'ils ont légué un héritage
qu'il faut faire vivre bon ce que ça a
changé c'est que les gens attendent
encore plus de nous et puis je crois
qu'une fois bourreau qu'avant peut-être
oui parce que
l'espérance et il est encore la barre
est plus haute
bon puis je crois qu'il faut être quand
même modeste dans la réussite c'est vrai
que bon on est peut-être mieux reçus
mais pour changer les choses sur le
terrain il faudra du temps l'intégration
la tolérance changer les mentalités
ça prendra du temps en même temps il
faut aller vite on va partir 92 c'est
l'europe
ouais ça veut dire que que le combat lui
seulement en france et oui on peut plus
imaginer qu'on va vivre dans notre
hexagone juste entre nous et que gère
pour a pu dire les emmerdeurs euros
c'est ce qu'on comprend pas c'est les
yvelinois non non il y aura deux noms
oui malheureusement il y en a aucun qui
soit aussi culotté cuit voilà dans les
gens quittaient y avait quelqu'un qui
t'a beaucoup [ __ ] c'était christophe
riboud qui malheureusement nous a
quittés et j'ai lu dernièrement dans la
presse que paul loup sulitzer elle est
aidée alors est-ce que c'est quelqu'un
qui a toujours eu beaucoup de [ __ ] est
ce que tu es nouveau nec de ce logiciel
non christophe reboosté un animiste et
plus que qu'un parrain de l'association
que quelqu'un qui nous aidaient c'était
bon c'était un pote
vrai
il ya des gens qui nous aident bon là il
ya un certain nombre de gens qui peut
être après des missions aussi mieux
compris que
notre message il n'était pas politique
au sens partisan que c'était un message
assez clairement passé ouais je crois
que c'est important c'est un message à
la fois morale et réaliste ce leader
alors et solidaire il fait partie de ces
gens là
c'est bien mais soit parce que c'est
très simple voilà parce que c'était
aussi une étonnement je prends pour un
certain nombre de gens que bon
conseiller financier quelqu'un qui est
un apôtre de l'argent bien fait et vite
fait et aussi un sens de la morale du
respect pour les autres un sens de la
dignité de ceux qui n'ont pas forcément
réussi comme lui et qui qui qui croient
que la société de demain n'a de sens que
si elle donne l'égalité des chances à
tous il et ça ça moi je le crois gens
sont ils en ont d'ailleurs paul loup
sulitzer il n'a pas dit quand avant il
est venu faire y compris hors enfin dans
une émission pour témoigner de son
succès souhaité racisme est lui même
d'origine immigrée c'est ce que c'est
que pas être compris
est ce que c'est que d'avoir à se battre
pour se faire reconnaître
alors ce soir je voudrais seulement de
poser des questions sur l'actualité je
pense qu'on aura l'occasion à noël de
faire toucher nos missions avec toi
enfin tous les cas je le souhaite
europe 1 c'est quoi cette histoire est
ce que c'est parce que
repas a besoin d'avoir des stars sur son
antenne est ce que c'est parce que tu es
mon argent et dans d'autres formats
moins qu'avant est ce que c'est parce
que tu as besoin d'argent est ce que
c'est parce que tu as envie de s'amuser
à faire de la radio
j'ai le droit de s'amuser mais non non
c'est vrai ça m'amuse ça me plaît c'est
un outil qui a beaucoup de souplesse et
d'ailleurs l'idée de l'émission qui
s'appelle surprise donc c'est que
d'abord il n'ya pas une régularité
obligatoires voilà on dit que c'est
mauvais mais moi j'ai envie de faire la
démonstration de la hutte pour talence
et à la botte peut-être mais qui vaut
mieux car j'ai quand on a quelque chose
à dire et que on a des vraies
informations apportées que on a des gens
intéressants à faire connaître que ce
soient des stars ou ce soir des inconnus
mais à qui on doit tirer son chapeau ou
à qui on doit donner la parole pour les
aider et donc l'émission sera deux fois
ou trois fois par mois
et puis en dehors de cette émission
surprise donc le dimanche matin de 11h à
12h et ni deux j'ai une collaboration
plus générale avec jean pierre elkabbach
ses directeurs dans divers bars tabacs
souhait c'est personnage assez étonnant
lui aussi d'avoir c'est un homme libre
indépendant
il m'a fait la proposition donc de
d'utiliser d'une certaine façon cet
outil qu'est la radio en portant mon
regard un mois sur la société avec mes
passions mes coups de colère mais aussi
avec peut-être des choses que les gens
ça moi on aime bien rire on est bien
l'humour parce que j'aime bien c'est
eddie murphy c'est woody allen ces gens
qui sont capables de prendre avec
dérision le malheur qu'on essaye de l'en
faire retomber sur les épaules et dans
l'émission et à jean benguigui un
certain nombre d'amis comique qui
viennent avec nous parce que bon on peut
avoir des idées sans pour autant pleuré
toute la journée il a trié la première
ça s'est passé comment bien ça a été un
peu cafouillé du point de vue de la
technique des programmes et l'important
c'est qu'il y avait une grande amitié
dans le studio une grande émotion
je crois qu'on a aussi montré des choses
qui existent qui sont sont plus
supportables dans la france
d'aujourd'hui on a montré comment si on
veut acheter un chien raciste basse est
possible de téléphoner à quasiment
n'importe quel jeune il ya deux ans
j'avais des copains de l'équipe jean
benguigui qui est comédien qui s'est mis
dans le rôle du chauffeur de taxi qui
cherchera si on a fait dire à plusieurs
thoniers on a trouvé à chaque fois un
chez racine dont l on appelle ça une
dépense et quand la prochaine
ça s'est déjà passé la problème c'est le
18 octobre 18 octobre merci à la main
très bien vous connaissez l'éjaculât le
feuilleton là
ce qui se passe au kenya avec les types
qui marchent en accéléré la voulait lui
semblait pas tellement chiant ça va et
ça on va voir la suite c'est donc max va
du recul c'est un film qui a été fait
pour une société qui s'appelle will i
wear et on peut voir les photos 56 rue
du faubourg saint-antoine
on peut voir les photos d'eva du recul
on peut voir la cassette du feuilleton
on va regarder c'est l'avant dernier
épisode puisque ce soir c'est la
quatrième émission
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
d
g
[Musique]
et
les
[Musique]
je suis le mieux
m
[Musique]
rien
ok
oui
[Musique]
ok
bonsoir tatiana tolstoï nous allons
parler un peu de mode parce que vous
êtes tous plus ou moins spécialistes ou
victimes de la mode alors tatiana
tolstoï vous avez écrit un livre
s'appelle de l'élégance masculine qui
est un vrai un véritable livre diktat
sur la mode parce que vous dites des
choses terrifiantes mes coaches alors
nous en parler un peu après vous êtes
aussi l'arrière petite fille de l'auteur
de guerre et paix bon alors on raconte
voilà dans ses coûts alors claude challe
qui est un dandy aussi à sa manière qui
est aussi une victime de la mode selon
certains mais il va s'en expliquer et
puis
et puis alain soral qui a écrit ce livre
s'appelle la création mode qui est
qui est un peu le b à ba pour comprendre
le système de la mode comment comment
fonctionne la botte comment on fait le
vêtement et comment le porte
j'ai voulu refaire lagarde et michard ce
qu'ils ont fait pour la littérature
j'aime leur là c'est un peu ça c'est
vrai et le
et aussi vous êtes aussi le co auteur de
des mouvements de mode explique aux
parents qui étaient abaissées hier sur
robert laffont il ya quelques années et
qui vient de sortir au japon voilà et
alors tiré à 10 ans qui porte un costume
gris en permanence une lacoste noire des
mocassins weston est normalement pas de
chaussettes
aujourd'hui elle a été avocate nationale
tolstoï elle dit que avait dû à tout
flou et j'ai tout faux mais c'est quand
même j'ai vu des flammes et des très
belles coupes c'est la dyle vous m'avez
dit que moi je parlais de mode dont je
parle pas du tout là c'est uniquement
classicisme et la référence à partir de
là le classicisme masculin s'est fixé
dans les années trente à peu près dans
ses formes actuelles et sa jungle dont
je parle je parle de ce qui sert de
référence à la salle vous croyez qu
aujourd'hui encore vous écrivez dans le
livre que on peut plus on n'a pas droit
de porter une jaquette et de rire en
même temps alors c'est un peu difficile
jaquette noir parce qu'on la porte au
deuil aussi 1 012 maroc par exemple
lorsque j'ai entendu dire bonjour en
contre côté eux-mêmes par exemple je
prône lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on compte un happy avance de
danser la france parce que les relais
les basques lire volts en même temps que
la le danseur et c'est vraiment
ravissant ah oui alors là vous rejoignez
votre arrière grand temps que ça devient
de poésie parce que vous dites aussi
qu'il faut on n'a pas le droit de porter
un loden à l'est à l'ouest du rhin et
sud des alpes
chérèque en loden en sicile c'est
difficile à moins de s'appeler ray man
ou seul j'ai eu le temps de le lire à
table discuter
moi je trouve que c'est utile un but
comme ça parce que c'est c'est comme ça
on sait c'est la règle quand le comme
l'homme élégance et celui en fait qu'il
est au delà des règles de temps
aujourd'hui s'il n'y a pas d'eau mais
les grands parce que ils sont au delà de
rien du tout mais ils connaissent grâce
à elle rompt nouveau connaître les
règles pouvoir être au delà des règles
devenir à nouveau les gants l'erreur ça
serait effectivement de faire ce qu'on
dit dans le livre parce que là on
passait juste à savoir jusqu'où
j'explique les conventions effectivement
grand mère mais ce qui m'a faire que
j'aurais recueilli oralement mais mais
cette grand-mère et les un petit peu
gelé
mitigés ont quelque chose en donnant
entre chaque chapitre exprime exprimant
les conventions je fais entrer
vestimentaire un nomade et élégant
actuelle et chaque portrait
vestimentaire est une exemple de
transgression ne sait avec le bien sûr
je trouvais qu'ils transgressent lui par
exemple mais il a un style ça c'est
certain
ok là le droit du point de vue classique
il est évident qu'il n'est pas classé
bien sûr mais la loi morale avec son
pouce en photo et son école en lapin
synthétique rester à temps
ça c'est la marmotte et j'ai une seule
vision impure de panique soient doublés
enregistrons mais j'ai pas mis la
doublure sociaux parce qu'ils font que
pas et alors lequel des délires il faut
acheter
mais eux sont complémentaires fois jeté
les deux avant d'acheter déjà mieux
à l'onu il vaut très cher parce que
c'est un livre un peu pour les
professionnels ayant plus ils ont de
l'envié traduit en anglais et il
fonctionne sur l'intérêt de ce bouquin
c'est qu'il est déjà prévendu aux écoles
de mode du prof du monde entier et qu'il
est déjà en corée et a dit rien mais moi
j'ai pas besoin vraiment de de rafler
les vitrines des librairies parce que
j'espère le vent à paris je vends ma
maîtrise de la mode et la maîtrise
française de la mode ce qu'on peut
encore les français maîtrisent le mode à
l'étranger notamment la consigne
emportements la livre du entre le livre
du frère d'agnès soral et la nièce de
tolstoï tu vois qu'ils arrêtent et
arrêter de la charia sur talk that talk
moi j'ai lu un bouquin de l'anarchisme
vérifier que les quatre pères fondateurs
de l'anarchisme modem ces jeux tir nre
bakounine proudhon et tolstoï
elle soigne est mort dans une gare
habillé en paysan la stratégie stavanger
et à la wii n'a pas c'est un noir c'est
révoltant et conformiste année des
paysans et j'emmerde avec ça parce que
d'abord on est l'arrière petit fils
usine de tolstoï connais très bien
moi mon arrière grand père mon grand
père était le premier schizo chez le
plus grand tailleur de genève
et c'est pas pour ça que je sais faire
un costume c'est moi prestigieuse donc
fatidique il faut acheter tant les
oiseaux vivent c'est tout le sens qu'il
faut acheter le vote au nom mais ce
serait élégant acheter garcia
il est bien aussi acheter le livre de
madame parce que c'est quand même les
bases je vois que les bases sont
importantes on peut pas construire sur
des mauvaises fondation oui je reste
important d'avoir des votes les gens
s'habillent trop mal j'en aux boys and
soul et non en maintenant les séquences
qu'il faut avoir qu'est-ce que l'âge de
départ pour pouvoir après délire et
s'ils aiment pas les bonnes bases de
départ ça part dans tous les sens qui
fait déjà saliver au portier des
bains-douches personnes rentrent sont
saisis way you lie de madaba wii n'ont
alors plus personne élégant non mais ça
n'est pas laisser claude a refusé il l'a
déjà dit les chiens ça ne se fermait
aussi une chose qu on oublie souvent
cette élégance c'est en soi il ya des
gens qui sont en tricot de corps chez
qui c'est un peu contre le tricot de
corps des gens qui sont beaucoup
d'élégance de cocteau il ya des gens en
smoking salaires des ploucs désole dans
nabi ils sont et resteront plus toute
leur vie le smoking
c'est à dire c'est pour moi c'est comme
le sac de pommes de terre c'est
tellement strictes et ya tellement peu
de variantes possibles que je veux dire
que sous on est élégant et auquel cas
c'est parfait ça ne l'est pas et on est
irrécupérable king c'est la chose qui
lui manque
j'étais seulement son élégant parce que
ce n'est pas élégant c'est certain que
mon livre part sur une île
je crois que c'était un calcul dans mon
éditeur pas du mien moi j'étais l'ami
informations le costume gris mais mon
éditeur s'est dit qu'il pourrait se
faire de l'argent en essayant de faire
croire à la clientèle qu'on peut devenir
élégant en lisant de sept-îles interdite
heures qui veut faire de l'argent c'est
acropole très bien ça vaut combien je
vois l'attaché de presse
ça vaut combien 95 francs ça vous laisse
10 franc parler ne reste pas à la porte
c'est quoi ces check it en ligne ben moi
c'est un petit éditeur à leurs appels et
c est ce qui fait que des bouquins pour
faire ça c'est ton livre japon ça ouais
ouais je suis quand même traduit en
japonais et en anglais dans celui-là et
en anglais ça c'est un bouquin fait par
un professionnel du niveau que les
tendances des méthodes de porc cetera
est ce un bouquin pourra pour que les
jeunes stylistes les professionnels
apprennent bon donc oui il faut qu'on
s'arrête là parce que c'est pas élégante
parler aux gens de l'élégance aussi
longtemps m'a d'ailleurs moi distendu la
juge donne une leçon sur merci
et
clm bonsoir bruno le moule sellem
bonsoir derrière nous c'est les coûts
gaillette
j'avais créé un style finalement on va
essayer on l'espère ouais maintenant on
dit des conseils à l'entendre ici dans
la rue qui a un style un peu absent du
nucléaire nous on le dit on sait pas si
tout le monde le dit elle elle dit des
coquillettes
ouais et après cette émotion tout le
monde dira alors la marque google
oui ce qui m'intéresse de savoir ce
départ comment ça s'est passé ça y est
quelqu'un qui est venu vous voir en me
disant je veux lancer une marque
oui malgré ce qu'on lui avait apportés
il existait déjà quand on les a vus il
n'existait pas depuis deux mois pourtant
d'année mais il existait et on s'est
rendu compte très vite que peu près
toutes les filles entre 15 et 25 ans
savait ce que c'était alors que nous
répondent tout à fait et puis
fesses on a regardé comment il était ce
qu'il était mais qui vendait des vendait
des vêtements pas chers qu'on retrouvait
finalement partout ouais on a essayé de
faire en sorte que la publicité montre
des choses qu'on voit partout
donc on essaie de mettre le plus
possible dans les magazines en noir et
blanc sont sur les affiches au cinéma la
télévision essayer que le cern petit peu
alors toi tu as fait les ti moi j'ai
fait les tiges tout est plutôt occupé
des images du mois plus tôt et qu'est ce
que tu as fait tu m'appeler des
stylistes
j'ai fait un peu de rap en anglais on a
bien travaillé pour ce fait ça en
angleterre j'ai
j'ai concédé une équipe avec elisabeth
géant et on a essayé de jeter avec des
gens qui retenait plus les plus
professionnelles dans la mode et
et pour tourner un petit peu en dérision
la mode est certaine
pour essayer de traduire un peu la façon
dont une fille elle s'habillait
éventuellement les fautes de goût
qu'elle pouvait faire qui nous
intéressait cette espèce de mélange un
peu un peu baroque qui
- avait peut-être le style coûteux pour
l'espère merci de trait bretons cette
double attentionné c'est pas honnête
c'est sûr mais c'est une campagne qui va
demander beaucoup d'argent
non parce qu'on à rentabiliser au
maximum ouais on nous a plongés dans le
noir et blanc ça coûte pas cher donc
sept ont payé cher
c'est un rhume des foins veulent pas
qu'il ya certains s'impatientent et aux
poudres c'est facile
c'est beaucoup mais chaque école
interprofessionnelle rester un peu à peu
le départ de l'idc
voulait être aussi des filles de la rue
et les rend complètement entre les looks
complètement insensé départ de li
d'émotion on voulait on voulait avec une
ondée donc il fallait maximum d'annoncer
c'est vrai qu'on pouvait pas que l'on
voulait suivre la même philosophie
kookaï eux mêmes mais qui changent de
mode souvent dont vous voulez changer
très souvent de cette annonce
d'où le noir et blanc qui a pendant la
shoah esthétique mais qu'elles soient
économiques plus synthétique c'est pas
mal brimés et donc effectivement c'est
des vainqueurs de chaque action
combien de budget sur la table parce
qu'on va les affiches kookaï dans tous
les sens ça fait combien de sousse à ces
quelques millions d'âmes et combien des
six mois je sais pas exactement où 3 400
cantons chez google
j'espère qu'ils sont là après hama près
vittel crm est en train de frapper un
super pourquoi pas exposé facile
puisqu'il vous engager
c'est un petit peu
nous fait quoi la dame campagne en ce
moment alors en ce moment qu'est ce
qu'on a fait ensemble on n'a fait qu'une
d'art ouais c'est bien voilà lui l'a
fait de son côté le coeur maintenant non
bah oui
les perles du film sinon malgré les
orangers à peine sous ses couleurs une
ont plein de choses des cas soit là
c'est à dire des gens qui travaillent
avec vous quand même il ya les jo
quand même c'est pas rien j'ai pas de
ace combat et les chapeaux ce qui les
chapeaux bercy c'était
départ
c'est soit des coiffures et là pour
changer un peu on a voulu faire la
chasse aux oies qu'en mai
à vous les faire travailler pour faire
travailler en fait on a enfin été déjà
peau du cou au berceau
c'est beau
[Musique]
mathilda may alors le cri du hibou et
chabrol ça sort quand ça sort le 28
octobre le 28 12
pourquoi tu pourquoi tu penses qu'on t'a
choisi toi ça c'est ce que les autres
c'est une bonne question c'est ce que je
me suis toujours demandé je crois qu'il
faut demander aux entrées tout parce que
c'est pas je sais pas pourquoi il a
choisi chabrol ce qu'avait chouette mais
serait chouette alors on la choisit pour
le crédit fallait quelqu'un sait combien
de deux jeunes actrices qui ont été en
lice mais je crois qu'il n'a eu aucune
parce qu'il m'avait vu dans d'autres
choses donc ouais dans un téléfilm qui
s'appelle les loups par exemple dans la
halle force dans la vie ni celui de
gérard huck de lecointe et donc ça lui a
plu et a pris comme ça oui
alors quel est ton rôle rêve ce truc
vraiment que à part la comtesse aux
pieds nus c'est quoi ton didier j'étais
très très frappé par le rôle de pandora
par exemple mais ça m'a beaucoup plu
alors dans les mac de pont de roide
effet un remake parce qu'après va garder
ses taux
qu'est-ce que tu restes de ton avec qui
avec plein de gens j'aime beaucoup m
gibson ton avec le bellâtre qui a du
talent c'est vrai sait-on combien thiem
film c'était le 10e n'a eu un vol depuis
non non c'est quoi les autres c'est
l'obsession de la passerelle avec encore
bien s'en sort quand et ça sort le 2
décembre va très bien merci
alors voilà on attend maintenant sur
lunettes nous allons maintenant on passe
au chouchou de la semaine c'était
j'allais tout laisse toute la semaine
alors ces prochains jours
alors là là la cérémonie alors parce que
ces groupes a créé quelques années le
dise que la musique ambiante sociale
dans les défilés de mode très bien fait
c'est très émouvant québécois des
analystes américains le chômage je
pourrais anglais vient d'angleterre et
il ya une fille qui fait tout pour
l'instant mais c'est toujours très bien
oui ça décrit bien le talent est là non
non tu connais
francis bacon
c'est là bas les gens qui voulaient que
les basses génial non enfin spécial
buteur ceux qui ont cru à un des
meilleurs spots le soir du spécial
beatles on trouve à rolling stone s'est
il adore paris il adore paris souvent de
passage à paris il adore les bains et on
a la chance de jouer au courant tout ce
qui se passe toutes les petites choses
ça qu'il s'agit
un modèle auquel est soumis le site
internet youtube est une ode à deux fils
octobre of 6 6 1 et 3 de first is your
love love me do you do you really au
spécial beatles and what we do in office
of octobre à six ans
cameron
c'est moi la peinture daniilidou
en fait ce sont les services auxquels
auront à toi maintenant
vas-y chaste et waiting son lobby
sioniste colson de you and you to i want
you like to sign
[Musique]
pour qu'elle penche la tête vers moi
touche mans
[Musique]
quelles sont en cas
des sentiments
pour que dans ses fatigues ces sommets
y'a que moi
chenet
au dim
ces variétés je traîne
j'ai tout simplement
ma fiancée mai
réserve de b
avec eux la
tous les messages que son coeur
tout aille sur ma joue
tu
c'est là qu'elle chante
tu parles
que tu déjà
ce qui me sidère
à tous qui sait
la pouvoir
simon
à essayer
jean
toutes les beaux bateaux et
je viens
oh
laisse tranquille
là
ces itinéraires
je sois moi
mes chansons
ja
on sent quelque chose comme une présence
ordinaire
pour terminer
après
et bein je chante encore
et sans
c'est tout c'est
tiens
c'est de l'alcool chanter
ou que tu parles jamais
que tu dises à
tout le monde
jeudi
c'est mieux
tout ce qui si ça plaît voilà
et vous
mais bon
oh
et là chez vous
j'en
le chemin
c'est pour ces colonies
c'est l'école chanter
tu parles
déjà
tout le monde
on subit
ce qui sait
pourquoi
c'est pour ces
qui
kita
pour tuer
[Musique]
aulas
c
tu
tu parles
jamais
je
[Musique]
ce qui si jobs
alors chanté une chanson des beatles
pour moi c'est toujours un plaisir
parmi toutes celles qui l'ont écrite il
y en a une que je préfère autant que les
autres c'est blackburn alors je vais la
chanter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
blackbird synonyme de dauphin
facebook à nantes ou fla
[Musique]
aulas
m
tout est dit
dès ce moment
[Musique]
auj
black bean games dead of night
[Musique]
tekken 6
aulas
il
fortis monter au vif les blacks
[Applaudissements]
cela
je ne la blâme
[Musique]
blackburn things not enough
orienté ce plan commun
le flou
non
tu as
10 me
[Musique]
bla
cela
il a tout
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la dignité
non
oh
à
nouvel époux
fordisme des fruits
yuuwaa la librairie
fort des sma
si free
tu vois
au fond du seau
jefferies je ne suis pas sur nos chaînes
nationales a alors enchaîné alors une
autre chanson que j'aime autant que
l'autre sur son que c'est vachement bien
et alors justement c'est son
anniversaire aujourd'hui cette chanson
elle a 25 ans aujourd'hui
thierry ardisson on parlait tout à
l'heure et elle s'appelle love me do
donc j'ai quand même drôle et alors
cette chanson j'ai chanté plein de
chansons quand j'étais au lycée d'une
chanson des beatles celle là je l'avais
jamais chanté et puis avec jacky tout à
l'heure on a répété de seconde et on va
voir ce que ça donne
voyons
[Musique]
oh
delanoë
une
elle
[Musique]
alors
et puis je
charpy
l'offre mais deux
oh
mais deux
[Musique]
une
à
oui c'est tout
j'oublie
[Musique]
la vidéo
aux yeux
serein
moi
chat
un jeu
tous là
mais
tu nous
oui je fais tout s'oublie
la vie dure
aux hommes et 2 reprend encore complet
ça
un tueur
charles est nu
ça
- sur la
ciao
un cul là
non
[Musique]
j'oublie
la v2
waouh
yeah
or
hu
alors laurent voulzy c'est les beatles
mais c'est aussi les antilles les
antilles c'est sétois justin beroard la
chanteuse de cassard alors tous les deux
je leur ai demandé ce soir pour bain de
minuit de chanter la chanson tu y es ce
que je préfère maladie d'amour
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ado
maladie d'amour maladie de la jeunesse
chasse et waimes à moi ou à mâcher des
mois
maladie d'amour à la vie de la jeunesse
a chassé la peur
cliqua de badji a mais en mieux puis
chemine encore fois depuis
pas cité
m
machete
aladin
l'adie de la jeunesse csaj chez moi
hu à mâcher derniers mois
l'échevine piti piti tout but
c'est anti c'est qu'on garde mes amis
mes fils y
on tue tête l'année en l'air
il est gâté
m
en coop échéant mots si métiers battre
aux côtés c'est l'homme
ces métiers
m
thibault
maladie dans leur jeunesse
chassez web
hu à mâcher
évidemment
l'avis de là
j'assume
mâcher des mois
puis chemine gamache et dans la
mary et ussel tout mon temps
tu as beau et gamache et jan kohout va
tout faire pour être moribond
tout à sa mort
et bien c'est juste pas
elle malade est dans mon maladie de
nager
châssis moins d'un mois croît pas chez
les
[Musique]
à dix dans leur jeu
geagea suez mais moi ma chère et moins
parade et d'amour
ag
charge sur moi
moi j'avais un mois
allah
chadi hammami
wacheux témoin
et
là
il
[Musique]
bah
oh
[Musique]
d
oh
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus